The coefficients n-choose-k
that we calculated in the
previous segment are known as
the binomial coefficients.
They are intimately related
to certain probabilities
associated with coin tossing
models, the so-called binomial
probabilities.
This is going to
be our subject.
We consider a coin which we
toss n times in a row,
independently.
For each one of the tosses of
this coin, we assume that
there is a certain probability,
p, that the
result is heads, which of
course, implies that the
probability of obtaining tails
in any particular toss is
going to be 1 minus p.
The question we want to address
is the following.
We want to calculate the
probability that in those n
independent coin tosses,
we're going to
observe exactly k heads.
Let us start working our way
towards the solution to this
problem by looking first
at a simple setting
and then move on.
So let us answer this
simple question.
What is the probability
that we observe
this particular sequence?
Of course here we take n equal
to six, and we wish to
calculate this probability.
Now, because we have assumed
that the coin tosses are
independent, we can multiply
probabilities.
So the probability of this
sequence is equal to the
probability that the first
toss is heads times the
probability that the second
toss is tails, which is 1
minus p, times the probability
that the third toss is tails,
which is 1 minus p, times the
probability of heads, times
the probability of
heads, times the
probability of heads.
And by collecting terms, this is
p to the 4th times 1 minus
p to the second power.
More generally, if I give you a
particular sequence of heads
and tails, as in this example,
and I ask you, what is the
probability that this particular
sequence is
observed, then by generalizing
from this answer or from the
derivation of this answer, you
see that you're going to get p
to the power number of heads.
And the reason is that each
time that there's a head
showing up in this sequence,
there's a corresponding factor
of p in this numerical answer.
And then there are factors
associated with tails.
Each tail contributes a
factor of 1 minus p.
And so we're going to have
here 1 minus p to a power
equal to the number of tails.
Now, if I ask you about the
probability of a particular
sequence and that particular
sequence has happened to have
exactly k heads, what is the
probability of that sequence?
Well, we already calculated
what it is.
It is the previous answer,
except we use the symbol k
instead of just writing out
explicitly "number of heads."
And the number of tails is the
number of tosses minus how
many tosses resulted in heads.
Now, we're ready to consider
the actual problem that we
want to solve, which
is calculate the
probability of k heads.
The event of obtaining
k heads can happen in
many different ways.
Any particular k-head sequence
makes that event to occur.
has a probability equal to
this expression.
The overall probability of k
heads is going to be the
probability of any particular
k-head sequence, times the
number of k-head sequences
that we have.
Now, the reason why we can carry
out this argument is the
fact that any k-head sequence
has the same probability.
Otherwise, we wouldn't be able
to write down an answer which
is just the product
of two terms.
But because every k-head
sequence has the same
probability, to find the overall
probability, we take
the probability of each one of
them and multiply it with the
number of how many
of these we have.
So to make further progress, now
we need to calculate the
number of possible
k-head sequences.
How many are there?
Well, specifying a k-head
sequence is
the same as the following.
You think of having
n time slots.
These time slots corresponds
to the different
tosses of your coin.
And to specify a k-head
sequence, you need to tell me
which ones of these slots happen
to contain a head.
You need to tell me
k of those slots.
So in other words, what you're
doing is you're specifying a
subset of the set of
these n slots, a
subset that has k elements.
You need to choose k of the
slots out of the n and tell me
that those k slots have heads.
That's the way of specifying a
particular k-head sequence.
So what's the number of
k-head sequences?
Well, it's the same as the
number of ways that you can
choose k slots out of the n
slots, which is our binomial
coefficient, n-choose-k.
Therefore, the answer to our
problem is this expression
here, times n-choose-k, which
is shown up here.
At this point, we can pause and
consider a simple question
to check your understanding of
the binomial probabilities.